the Senate Judiciary Committee will
likely decide to proceed with judge
Brett Kavanaugh a Supreme Court
nomination this morning barely 14 hours
after a fiery and emotional day of
testimony Cavanaugh and Christine Bazzi
Ford who claims he sexually assaulted
her in high school told they're
contradicting stories to a worldwide TV
audience Capitol Hill and the nation had
not seen a display like this in a
generation I am here today not because I
want to be I am terrified I am here
because I believe it is my civic duty
this is a circus the consequences will
extend long past my nomination after the
hearing ended the American Bar
Association which gave Kavanagh its
highest rating called on the Senate to
put its vote on hold until the FBI can
investigate the allegations of abuse the
ABA says a Supreme Court nomination
quote is simply too important to rush to
a vote Nancy Cordes has covered the
Kavanagh confirmation from the beginning
she's still covering the Kavanagh
confirmation she's on Capitol Hill right
now Nancy good morning good morning
those 51 Republican senators met late
last night to discuss where they now
stand after this hearing and they also
got an assessment from that prosecutor
who was in the hearing Rachel Mitchell
they wouldn't tell us much about what
she said but the fate of Brett Kavanaugh
now rests with a handful of undecided
senators do you swear that the testimony
you're about to give before this
committee will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth it was a
day that transfixed Washington and the
country dr. Ford with what degree of
certainty do you believe Brett Kavanaugh
assaulted you 100%
none of these allegations are true
correct no doubt in your mind zero I'm
100% certain the committee listened
first to Christine Blasi Ford a
psychologist fretts assault on me drive
drastically altered my life she said
Kavanagh hindered our high school party
I believed he was going to rape me I
tried to yell for help
when I did
put his hand over my mouth to stop me
from yelling Republicans treated Blasi
for gingerly ceding their time to
veteran sex crimes prosecutor Rachel
Mitchell you believed it occurred in the
summer of 1982 and you said the end of
your sophomore year the 10:00 Committee
Democrats universally behind Ford what
is the strongest member you have
indelible in the hippocampus is the
laughter the laughte
uproarious laughter between the two and
they're having fun at my expense
Cavanaugh came out swinging as some in
his party had advised I have never done
this to her or to anyone
he said the accusations from Blasi Ford
and two other women had ruined his life
yeah the night Ashley and my daughter
Liza said their prayers and little Liza
all 10 years old said to Ashley we
should pray for the woman it's a lot of
wisdom from a 10 year old Democrats
asked Cavanaugh about alcohol use you're
saying there's never been a case where
you drink so much that you didn't
remember what happened the night before
or part of what happened you're asking
about yeah blackout I don't know have
you could you answer the question judge
they also pressed him repeatedly to back
an FBI background investigation which
Cavanaugh will you support an FBI
investigation right now I I will do
whatever the committee wants personally
do you think that's the best thing for
us to do Republicans honed in on Blasi
Ford's lack of corroborating witnesses
and if you really wanted to know the
truth you sure as hell wouldn't have
done what you've done to this guy
eventually partisan anger reached a
boiling point are you a gang rapists no
boy y'all want power god I hope you
never get it I hope the American people
can see through this sham that you knew
about it and you held it you had no
intention of protecting dr. Ford no
to give you a sense of the agonizing
decision that these undecided senators
have to make shortly I want to read to
you what Arizona Senator Jeff Flake a
Republican said to us last night quote
there is no way you can leave that here
in room certain that you're completely
right he's right she's wrong
she's right he's wrong I mean you're
just never certainly you just do the
best you can that's what we're trying to
do and he's gonna have to do it in just
a couple of hours beyond them
yeah from sure Nancy won't take away is
there really is no winner in all of this
thank you